[Music]
welcome back guys we are going to
continue with our e captures d5 main
line whereupon we look at that after e4
queen to e2
knight to f6
what to do against the move knight to c3
in my last episode
whereupon in this one
we are going to consider one of the most
critical response
namely d3
which is of course recommended in many
books and videos
now the key thing you have to remember
here that
whenever white plays d3
we are going to respond with queen
captures d5
and white has two major choices
now knight b to d2 is by far the most
critical response
but first let's look at why knight to c3
is such a bad move in this position
because
after this
we can simply respond with
bishop to b4 pinning down the knight
and after bishop to d2 unpinning
we can sets up a crafty trick here
starting with
bishop capture c3 bishop capture c3
and now castle on the king's side
it's amazing that how many people has
fallen into this in my blitz games
as you can see from here that there are
more than 2400 plus games continue with
bishop captures f6 which is in fact a
great time disaster
because
black has this cunning in-between move
pawn captures f3 attacking the queen
queen captures f3
now we exchange the queen
and i really don't want to capture this
bishop immediately
rather i prefer rook to eat shack
the point is after king to d2
now we are going to take this bishop
when white give this check
you can see that king do not need to go
to the etched square instead
f it is ideal square
and by end of the sequence if you count
the material
black is a clear piece up
so this is one of the crafty trick exist
if your opponent continue with bishop
captures f6
well what happens if white spot this
and continue with
d captures e4
[Music]
and against this my recommendation is
very simple you just take this pawn with
your knight
and now the only move which keeps white
in the game is
rook to d1 attacking the queen which is
indeed supporting this e4 knight
but tactics favors black here and
after the following forcing sequence
knight captures c3
rook captures d5 knight captures e2
bishop captures e2
now you play bishop to e6 attacking the
rook
and when rook goes anywhere let's say
rook to d2 we can continue with knight
to c6
and at the end of the sequence
yes indeed we have equal material
but black is steaming ahead in terms of
peace development and this line is
slightly favoring the black camp
so this is all you need to know if your
opponent continue with knight to c3
well we come to most important junction
and that is
what happens if your opponent continue
with knight b to d2
but before we look at it the small point
in case if white takes on e4
i recommend you straightforwardly
capture with the queen
and as the queen are going to be
exchanged this position will remain
equal
and whoever play better
might get the winning chances
so let's check out what we are going to
do against the most critical response
namely knight b to d2
so white is attacking three times on the
pawn
and now it is ill advised to hold on to
the spawn
so i propose you continue with
knight to c6
and now white has two major choices
and amongst them
d captures e4 is the main line however
we should also know
what to do against the move knight
catches e4
okay white is ready to give us discover
check
so black should block it with the bishop
and white will be delighted as you can
see from the database
majority of the games continue with
knight catches f6
pawn captures f6
destroying the black pawn structure on
the king side
and now
what can be more natural than queen to
e4
so that if black exchanged the queen
then white has a completely winning
endgame
well it is not so simple as black has
this very cunning check in the mix
and the big point is after bishop to d2
we are going to play queen to b6
attacking the weak b2 pawn
again if you look at the database
as i have highlighted over here
castle as well as bishop to c3 are the
popular choices
and let's see what we are going to do
about them
the first move i want to consider is
castle
whereupon black can throw this nasty
surprise
a move which has been never been played
that is
queen to a6
and surprisingly this move turns out
very well for the black
we are already attacking on a2
and if you think that well it's not a
big deal i can always play a3 right
guess what this is exactly black wands
yes black has this nice tactic in the
picture
bishop captures a3 what a move
so the obvious thing is if white
foolishly take this bishop
then after queen takes we have prettiest
mate on the board with the following
sequence
king to b1 queen check
king to steven and queen to even
decide the game
so capturing the bishop
is right out of the equation
the more natural move here is bishop to
c3
defending the pawn as well as attacking
on f6
but now black can calmly retrieve back
the bishop on the e7 square
and
not only black regain his material but
he has a simple plan
namely castle on the queen side and then
try to launch attack on the white king
i like to show you my recent game in
this line where my opponent continued
with
bishop to e2
i castle on the quin side and now he
played the most obvious choice
namely d4
trying to get a piece
okay i respond with queen to a4
pinning down that pawn
so my opponent tried to protect his
queen with rook h to even
but i think this is too little too slow
black responded with f5
and after queen to e3
the winning shot of the game
knight to b4
well my opponent really doesn't like
that night so he literally chopped it
off
but this turned out as a big time
disaster
as after simple continuation queen check
king to d2
bishop to b4 check
and unfortunately for my opponent he has
no way to hide as after c3 i simply
checkmate him with queen captures b2
king to d3
and now queen capture c3
deliver the knockout punch
so i think this queen a6 novelty can
literally shock your opponent and you
get some fast victory in this variation
okay the second and the most popular
choice here is
bishop to c3
which again looks very natural as white
is not only defending on b2 but also
attacking on f6 but
unfortunately for wide black has a very
strong move here
that is bishop to b4
now if white captured this bishop then
knight captures b4 is a very strong
reply
so accordingly the base sequence goes as
follow
bishop to e2
now we chop on c3 and after pawn takes
black can simply respond with queen to
e5
trying to gobble up the c3 pawn
which
no wonder white can hardly defend it
so after white castles we take on c3 and
as you can see i have highlighted over
here black has a very simple plan namely
castle put the rook on the g file
and if possible in some line we can chop
on c2 as well
all in all i think practically speaking
this is good position to play as a black
camp
so now we come to the most important
junction of the whole elephant gambit
complex
as almost all the videos and books
recommend here
d captures e4
afterwards if you check the database
queen to h5 is exclusively played
but personally i don't think this line
is working for black and white obviously
get a nagging edge in this variation
so instead of this i am going to propose
my own invention in this line starting
with queen to e6
the point is we want to quickly castle
on the queen side
and because white has played the move
queen to e2 and knight to d2
he has somewhere down the line
slow down his complete piece development
so we are going to take benefit out of
it
if the opponent plays c3 then my
recommendation is you continue with
bishop to c5
however
if you check the database
almost majority of the games continue
with queen to c4
which is again looks very natural
white is trying to exchange the queen as
he's upon earth and rightly enough we
are going to decline it with this very
nice move
which is in fact hardly played in few
games and that is
queen to g4
here it doesn't matter whether white
continue with e5 or h3
black can sets up a nasty
peace sacrifice line which give him a
completely winning age
so by far engine's top choice is h3
and after our queen to g6
now white plays e5 attacking the knight
of course if black has to move that
knight then white position is extremely
good
but here i propose a nice piece
sacrifice line starting with
bishop to e6
which at first sight looks very funny
because white can play the move queen to
b5
attacking too soft spot
but you know what we just go for it
starting with castle on the queen side
sacking the whole night
and the big point is after pawn takes f6
you might think
hang on you lost whole piece for no
compensation right
well that's not the case here because
black has a stunning reply here
queen to c2
and now surprisingly black has a very
cunning idea that is rook to d5 and
trapping down the white sweetie
isn't that amazing
well recently i got this position
against a feeder master
and i think this game will give you
a model illustration how dangerous this
line is for the wide
well my opponent continue with f
captures g7
and after bishop captures g7
he simply responded with
bishop to e2
trying to castle on the king's side
okay
as i highlighted earlier i continue with
rook to d5 attacking the queen
and my opponent calmly played queen to
c4
going for the exchange
but what has been missed out is black
has this nice move
rook captures d2
a discover attack as well as nabbing the
knight
so white response is force he has to
exchange this queen
and indeed after this if you count the
material it is balanced
but in terms of peace development black
is way ahead
and in fact
i did cash in
based on this factor after white's
bishop to d1
i decided to simply sack an exchange
with
rook captures b2
bishop captures b2
rook to b1
and now my big point is
at the end of the sequence i want to
deliver this shack
so that wherever the king goes
i can nab an extra pawn on
a2 and if you count the material yes
indeed black is an extreme down
but it take ages for this white rook to
come out
and the most important factor is i have
three connected passporn
which can create a great headache for
the white cam
in upcoming endgame
all in all i think it is only black who
can have all kind of fun from this
position
that's it guys i hope with this mini
lecture
now you get all the information to play
against the move
d3 remember at this point
it doesn't matter however white get
extra pawn with either d captures e4 or
knight captures e4
as i have shown in this video
black is fully equipped with the
tactical resources
and any of your human opponent
can get outplayed easily
if he does not play accurately
from the given position
well thank you for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you in my next episode
very soon
bye and take care